hello everyone and welcome to a game you
were requesting ever since it happened
but we were kind of busy and we're only
uh getting around to showing it now it
happened like a week ago in the
chess.com online olympiad uh where uh
alexandre costaneux played irena crush
and this is just the one incredible
incredible game
as it often is with such incredible
games the beauty of the game is not only
in the movies that were played but uh
more often than not in the movies that
were not played so let's just check it
out and see why this game
is so so impressive so uh question with
the white pieces opens with e4 uh we
have c5 by crash going for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 d6 and now d4 so
nothing out of the ordinary here
characters captures uh knight to f6
knights the c3 and now uh pretty much in
every game that we've had the sicilian
defense in the past few videos we always
had the neighbor of defense but here we
have the classical variation uh knight
to c6 and how can uh how can you
proceed here uh and interestingly the
classical variation is only the third
more most popular sicilian first is of
course the neither of them is the dragon
and then it's the classical sicilian so
maybe something to try and take um
kostanio out of preparation uh we have
bishop to g5 still the most popular way
to counter the traditional sicilian the
rifter rouser attack we have e6 and now
queen to d2 the queen will
allow the the white king to go queen
side you're going to castle nicely you
have uh eyes on that bishop on g5 so if
queen to a5 maybe the bishop will not be
attacked so uh very nice placement for
the queen and you still keep an eye on
this knight so bishop to e7 continuing
development and now queen side castles
and now what do you play here uh well
you the most popular ideas here are just
castles or the immediate knight captures
on d4 but arena here goes for a6 uh and
if you've uh ever tried the learning uh
the sicilian from an old book it they
they always say that it's uh
you have to be very careful not to mix
up lines if is asics a part of the
traditional sicilian in this setup is
another part of it is it only in the
night or is it useful here of course
it's always useful to take away the b5
square because so many of the white's
pieces are going after this square
but
it's uh it is somewhat rarer than the
other continuation so let's see how
white proceeds here well uh you have a
chance to mess up a black spawn
structure so let's do this knight
captures on c6 b captures on c6 and now
bishop captures on f6 and you can't
capture with the bishop because you hang
the d6 pawn so g captures on f6
and now bishop the c for nicely
developing uh and here
what can black do well here you could
continue with uh some like bishop b7
queen to c7 maybe castle queen side okay
our pawn structure on the queen side is
a little messed up but so is uh your
pawn chain uh on the king side and as a
white um uh already castled queen side
maybe white will not be so eager to push
those queen side pawns to to attack the
black king there maybe you could leave
the king in the center of the board as
all of these spawns are maybe nicely
protecting it but we have castles uh
king side now whether this is castling
to safety or not let's see what happened
here there is one game in the database
between daniel vocatoro and
greenfield where uh h4 was played with
the idea of
rook h3 rook to g3 and bringing the rook
into the attack this way but kostanuk
plays rook h to e1 and it is now only as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game the idea is similar you want to
bring the rook into the game and start
some sort of an attack against the black
king if you can get maybe your rook on
h3 queen h6 deliver queen h6 checkmate
will be very good for white but of
course that's a lot of moves and black
will have something to say about this so
king to h8 of course you want to free up
the the g file for the rook we have rook
to e3 going for that rook lift and rook
the g8 now
uh and here we have uh
f4 by white it's a very interesting move
that grabs more space here yes you now
have very nice control uh and you allow
the queen to defend the g2 pawn but also
it's a waiting move you are waiting to
see if black will try some sort of an
attack of his own or of her own with uh
rook to b8 queen to b6 maybe going after
the pawn here but it's never easy
because the bishop can always go to b3
and you will have to waste some moves
before you can dislodge this bishop and
create some sort of an attack it just
feels like white's attack is happening a
little bit faster so what's the
principle thing to do as always when
you're attacked on the king side you
will counter attack in the center end so
uh irina does she plays d5 now
challenges the bishop here and now
before reacting to this queen to e2 now
the
capturing of the bishop is impossible as
you would hang your queen on d8 so
bishop to d6 now capturing of the bishop
is definitely possible but also just
bishop captures on f4 as the rook and
king are on the same diagonal so the
only move that helps white here is e5
goes after the bishop uh we have f
captures f captures on e5 and now bishop
to c5 now your rook is attacked and also
your bishop is attacked so what can you
do here
rook to h3 and this rook the h3 move is
a beautiful beautiful uh peace sacrifice
you can't capture the bishop directly uh
but you can capture it indirectly
because the queen to g5 check then your
your queen is no longer on the d file
and then you pick up the bishop and this
is exactly what irina does she plays
queen to g5 check king to b1 and only
now d captures on c4 so the piece has
been sacrificed but the lines of attack
have been opened so how do you continue
here uh of course there is but one move
knight to e4 attacks the queen and the
bishop and this is where the fun really
starts because how how can black even
continue here you have to be extremely
precise otherwise you're just getting
destroyed
uh one fine example of this is what if
queen captures sanji to you offer a
queen trade uh everything is hanging the
the queen will be attacked the knight
will be attacked the rook will be
attacked so how can how can white stop
this well if queen captures on g2
we have a very nice uh attack here with
rook captures on h7 king captures and
now knight to f6 with check and now the
king cannot go to the g file because
then we pick up the queen the rook will
no longer be defending the queen so you
have to play king to h8 now queen to h5
check king to g7 now comes king queen to
h7 check king to f8 and now queen to h6
with check and now it doesn't matter
what you play uh if you block with the
queen then we deliver the very nice rook
to d8 to check and now after the king
moves now we go for rook captures on g8
we sacrifice our queen and if black
doesn't accept it there's really nothing
for black to do here if you capture of
course this is checkmate and other
things don't really help so here the
black the white queen um cannot be
captured and uh well other than that you
really don't have a move so after queen
to h6 check you can't really block with
the queen in this variation you have to
play something else you have to move the
king right away but even this doesn't
help because the king is now in the
mating net we're just going to play
knight to g8 with knight captures on g8
with check and uh it doesn't matter if
you capture the knight then queen to f6
check and it's all over it doesn't
really matter what
what black does and if king the e8 we
just repeat knight to f6 check king e7
we're gonna play queen to h8 and there's
no defense here other gay either getting
checkmated here or if you somehow try to
defend this square with the rook then
rook to d7
is also checkmate so this is what
happens if you play something like queen
captures on g2 seems like a perfectly
fine move but it doesn't help uh if you
just uh ignore that bishop hanging on c5
and play some like queen to g6 saying
okay you do whatever you want i just
want to survive the attack after knight
captures on c5 there is still not all
that much for black to do there there
really isn't anything you can play i
mean that knight is just going to return
to f6 and then the attack starts starts
all over again with black being down
that bishop and if you capture here on
g2 again just queen to h5 and there's
really not much you can do here
uh you can stop the attack for now queen
g6 queen h4 but still the white's
position black's position is just
terrible uh the rooks are not yet
connected there's no way to develop this
bishop the knight controls all the
squares the pawns are blocking this
bishop
without developing the bishop you can't
really develop the rook so this is a
completely winning game for white so the
third option and the one that irina
chooses is queen captures an e5 this
defends the bishop here and also asks
what is your move now you don't have the
f6 square for your knight i just removed
the defender i can always just capture
it and there's no rook captures on h7
followed by some sort of a check because
the queen covers both f6 and the g5 so
here we have after queen captures an e5
rook to h5 the only way to continue the
attack now forcing the black queen to
move uh and this is the
uh critical moment of the game here
black has to play a move that you really
don't want to play and that is queen to
g7 you have to say all right your your
attack has merit i'm gonna give up the
peace and then try and survive and uh
had black done this the the game would
probably continue for example rook
captures and see five we can play rook
to b8 threaten checkmate and after you
stop this with some like b3 let's say c
captures eight captures and now we can
even play e5 we stop this rook from
going back to the king side to help out
with the attack we free our e6 square
for our bishop we could also play bishop
to f5 and black black definitely has
compensation white is uh overall better
but
black definitely has compensation but in
the game uh black uh tried to hold on to
everything played f5 uh but this runs
into
well a very very unfortunate move for
black uh so uh don't pause the video
just yet i'm gonna show you the move uh
the move is knight to g5 so again the
queen is offered but the queen cannot be
captured if queen captures an e2 then
rook captures an h7 is checked maybe
there's no stopping that
and what do you play here well you have
to keep an eye on the h7 square
otherwise you're getting checkmated of
course you can't play anything with the
rook then we can even play rook to d8 or
the queen is hanging here so the queen
has to move queen to c7 but now feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only way to win for white or rather
the the absolute quickest way while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh another offer of a queen that cannot
be accepted and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course queen to e5 with check that's the
good stuff uh this is what um uh
alexandra played and congratulations to
everyone who fathered found that you are
an excellent offer of queens that cannot
be captured uh so what can you play here
of course if the queen is captured rook
captures an h7 checkmate that's not
possible so rook to g7 this is pretty
much the only move that allows black to
prolong the game a little bit and now
another beautiful moment you could of
course play rook captures on h7 the rook
on g7 is pinned so this is possible but
this is only a mate in four and it seems
that kostanuk wanted to play a perfect
game here and she rather goes for a
mating three and that's rook to d8 with
check now we offer a rook and the rook
not only can be accepted but has to be
accepted if you just block with the
bishop then this will be checkmate after
rook captures so the rook has to be
accepted and now of course comes rook
captures an h7 check the queen no longer
guards the rook here the rook cannot
move as it's uh pinned by the queen from
e5 we have king to g8 and now queen
captures and ga g7 with checkmate and
this amazing amazing game with only 26
moves um uh occurred uh
in the video online chess olympiad 2021
so truly an impressive game uh the the
these games are just incredible when you
have like a queen offered that cannot be
accepted and again and again and again
and again if you remember um a
girlfriend's game against hikaru
nakamura also the the immortal queen
game or or steinitz immortal rook also
that that rook just that just kept
gobbling up pawns along the seventh rank
and could not capture them those are all
you know games to you know
enjoy for for ages and i believe this is
one such game so thank you for
suggesting it and i really hope you guys
enjoyed it and also uh before i forget
if you guys are interested in checking
out um uh kostenyuk's uh uh version of
the of the story uh she also made a
video on this game for chess.com channel
so i will put that uh in the description
below it will be the first thing you see
so uh do check it out if you want it
also starts with hello everyone so it's
it's good from the start uh so yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
thanks so much for suggesting it if you
have any other games we were too busy to
cover the olympia do use hashtag
suggestion and i will go through them uh
i would like to thank shanti chaganti
matthias binte federico conte alfredo
zachary bell and the mike pomeraning for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and on
what what else is happening in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day